we're discussing a lot about these large
language models and we're sort of
projecting these cognitive states of
ourselves on them but I think on the AI
front a lot more needs to happen so
basically right now it's these language
models and we believe that within their
parameters we're encoding these types of
things
and you know in some aspects it might be
true it might be truly emergent
intelligence that's coming out of that
in other aspects I think we have a ways
to go so basically to make all of these
dreams that we're sort of discussing
come come reality
we basically need a lot more reasoning
components
a lot more sort of logic causality
models of the world and I think all of
these things will
will need to be there in order to
achieve what we're what we're discussing
and we need more explicit
representations of these knowledge more
explicit understanding of these
parameters and and I think the direction
in which things are going right now is
absolutely making that possible by sort
of enabling you know chat GPT and gpt4
to sort of search the web and you know
Plug and Play modules and all of these
sort of components
in Marvin Minsky is the Society of Mind
you know he truly thinks of the human
brain as a society of different kind of
capabilities
and right now a simple a single such
model
might actually not capture that and I
sort of truly believe that
by sort of this side by side
understanding of Neuroscience and sort
of new neural architectures
that we still have
several breakthroughs I mean the
Transformer model was one of them the
attention uh sort of aspect the you know
memory component
all of these you know the representation
learning the pretext training of being
able to sort of predict the next word or
predict a missing part of the image and
the only way to predict that is to sort
of truly have a model of the world
I think those have been transformative
paradigms but I think going forward when
you think about AI research what you
really want is perhaps more inspired by
the brain perhaps more that is just
orthogonal to sort of how human brains
work
but sort of more of these types of
components well it's I think it's also
possible there's something about us that
uh in different ways could be expressed
you know Noam Chomsky you know he wants
to you know we can't have intelligence
unless we really understand
deeply
language the linguistic underpinnings of
of uh of reasoning but these models seem
to start building
deep understanding of stuff yeah because
what does it mean to understand because
if you keep talking to the thing and it
seems to show understanding that's
understanding it doesn't need to present
to you a schematic of look yeah this is
all I understand you can just keep
prodding it with prompts and it seems to
really and you can go back to the human
brain and basically look at places where
there's been accidents for example the
corpus callosum of some individuals you
know can be damaged and then the two
hemispheres don't talk to each other so
you can close one eye and give
instructions that the
that half the brain will interpret but
not be able to sort of project to the
other half and you could basically say
you know go grab me a beer from the
fridge and then you know they go to the
fridge
and they grab the B and they come back
and they're like hey why did you go
there oh I was thirsty turns out they're
not thirsty they're just making a model
of reality they're basically you can
think of the brain as the employee
that's like afraid to do wrong or afraid
to be caught not knowing what the
instructions were
where our own brain
makes stories about the world to make
sense of the world
and we can become a little more
self-aware
by being
more explicit about what's leading to
these interpretations
so one of the things that I do is every
time I wake up I record my dream I just
voice record my dream and sometimes I
only remember the last scene but it's an
extremely complex scene with a lot of
architectural elements a lot of people
Etc and I will start narrating this and
as I'm narrating it
I will remember other parts of the dream
and then more and more I'll be able to
sort of retrieve from my subconscious
and what I'm doing while narrating is
also narrating why I had this dream like
oh and this is probably related to this
conversation that I had yesterday or
this is probably related to the worry
that I have about something that I have
later today Etc so in a way I'm forcing
myself to be more explicit about my own
subconscious
and I kind of like the concept of
self-awareness in a very sort of brutal
transparent kind of way it's not like oh
my dreams are coming from outer space
and I mean all kinds of things like no
here's the reason why I'm having these
dreams and very often I'm able to do
that I have a few recurrent locations a
few recurrent architecture elements that
I've never seen in the real life but
that are sort of truly there in my dream
and and that are that I can sort of
vividually remember across many dreams
I'm like oh I remember that place again
that I've gone to before Etc and I and
it's not just Deja Vu like I have
recordings of previous streams where
I've described these places
so interesting these places
however much detail you could describe
them in
you you can you can place them onto a
sheet of paper through introspection yes
through this self-awareness that it
comes all from this particular machine
it's exactly right yeah
and I I love that about being alive like
the fact that I'm not only experiencing
the world but I'm also experiencing how
I'm experiencing the world sort of a lot
of this introspection allows the
self-growth I I love this dance for
having uh you know the language models
at least GPT 3.5 and 4 seem to be able
to do that too yeah you seem to explore
different kinds of things about what
um you know you could actually have a
discussion with it of the kind why did
you just say that yeah and it starts to
wonder yeah why did I just say that yeah
you're right I was wrong
I was wrong it was doesn't yeah and then
there's this weird kind of losing
yourself in the confusion of your mind
and it of course it might be
anthropomorphizing but there's a feeling
like almost of a Melancholy feeling of
like oh I don't have it all figured out
almost like losing your you're supposed
to be a knowledgeable a perfectly
fact-based knowledgeable language model
yeah and yet you fall short so human
self-consciousness uh in in my view may
have a reason through
building mental models of others this
whole fight or flight kind of thing uh
that that basically says
I interpret this person as about to
attack me or you know I can trust this
person Etc and we constantly have to
build models of other people's
intentions
and that ability to encapsulate intent
and to build a mental model of another
entity
is probably evolutionarily extremely
advantageous because then you can sort
of have meaningful interactions you can
sort of avoid being killed and being
taken advantage of
Etc
and once you have the ability to make
models of others
it might be a small evolutionary leap to
start making models of yourself
so now you have a model for other
functions and now you can kind of as you
grow have some kind of introspection of
hmm maybe that's the reason why I'm
functioning the way that I'm functioning
and maybe which igbt is doing is in
order to be able to again predict the
next word it needs to have a model of
the world
so it has created now a model of the
world and by having the ability to
capture models of other entities when
you say you know say it in the tone of
Shakespeare or in the tone of Nietzsche
Etc you suddenly have the ability to now
introspect and say why did you say this
oh now I have a mental model myself and
I can actually make inferences about
that